[Music]
this is
the ramsey show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice dr john deloney
ramsey personality
and host of the vastly popular dr john
dolone
podcast is my co-host today we'll be
taking your calls and your questions
about your life because he's here and he
can help you with your life
and i've always got an opinion about it
because i'm an expert on my opinion
and we'll talk about your money too if
you want the phone number is free and
some say the advice
is worth what you pay for it the phone
number triple eight eight two five
five two two five joe's gonna start off
this hour in boston hey joe what's up
hey james how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so i'm uh 22 years old and graduating
college in a couple weeks
um i'll be getting married in the fall
my fiance will also be
graduating uh we're really excited for
that both of us congratulations
it's awesome man thank you thank you
so excited um we're both debt-free i'm
going to be making about 45
000 after graduation she's probably
going to be
in a similar ballpark maybe a little
less but not that much
we currently have about 20 25
000 in saving which a good chunk
actually comes from the unemployment
assistance and we're just you know a
little concerned about that you know
with some of the new legislation
going forward as you know if we might
have to pay it back so we're we're
trying to figure out the the best way to
just make smart decisions with you know
an apartment
or probably not buying a house but
you know a living situation and just uh
how to be
you know financially responsible to live
well going forward
way to go what's your degree in what's
her degree in
minds in theology first in psychology
and elementary education
okay so are you going to become a pastor
or what are you going to do
i'm going to be a youth minister at a
catholic church nearby in the area
wonderful good for you okay cool thank
you very fun
all right well uh you know it sounds
like you got a lot on your plate
uh it's gonna be an exciting 12 months
agreed
yeah yeah absolutely we're very excited
so why boston
i just grew up here um you know big big
red sox fan big
awesome sports fan and you know we're
both from the area and
love it you know playing playing to stay
uh around
around here okay well buying a home is a
good thing
as a part of the scope of your life uh
it's a complicated thing it's a big
decision
uh there's a lot of moving parts to it
uh obviously it requires money it's
one of the largest purchases you'll ever
make in most cases and uh
so i recommend something that's highly
uncomfortable
because everybody's running around going
get a house get a house get a house get
a house because all renters go to hell
get a house get a house get a house get
a house right
you know it's like like renting is evil
or something you know what i'm saying
and i don't want you to be a renter when
you're 32
you're 22. okay but but i don't want you
to add a house purchase
to the busiest year of your life ever
you're graduating getting new jobs
getting married
i mean my god the last thing you want to
do is hang curtain rods
yeah okay i mean really it causes
divorces
but um yeah so i i we always joke and
say you'll make a
the serious thing is you'll make a
better decision one year after marriage
about which house to purchase
because you'll know each other better
you've got all of this busyness and
craziness in your rearview mirror
and it'll be a calm steady wise decision
you're out of debt you have your
emergency fund you have a good down
payment
that's a good decision i got to get a
house because i'm getting married
is about the way you make a stupid
mistake and by the way it takes about a
year of being married to know how close
to your mother-in-law to by
i was gonna say two or three years but
one's a minimum
and maybe yeah i'd get the smallest the
smallest place y'all can afford to live
in
like you're not trying to prove anything
to anybody you're getting to know each
other that was a mistake i made coming
out of colleges i rented this big
freaking nice place that was like three
times more expensive than i should
just because i could afford it and it
was all rented money it says wasted
money
right and i stayed there six months and
then we moved in the stinky butt little
apartment started saving money
and we had bugs in our first apartment
man it was i want you to do that
i'm not saying it was great i'm just
saying we should sign up for buzz we
survived we lived
well yeah but we're not yeah and we
learned to have some conversations that
we wouldn't have had
yeah it's okay to go small and clean
nobody yeah
yeah no rats you don't need any pets in
there just you too
just spend the year spend the year
enjoying your first year of marriage and
your first year of starting off at adult
life with all these jobs and graduations
and all this stuff
and you know and you will make a much
better decision a year later
and you be out of debt have your
emergency fund and have your down
payment and but everybody's going to put
pressure on you because everybody's a
freaking genius you're 22
you're gonna die if you don't buy a
house horse crap you're not gonna die
i've never considered um hitting you up
dave to create a dave ramsey t-shirt but
a t-shirt that said all runners go to
hell would sell
really well that's a fantastic but isn't
it the way people talk about it oh they
talk about it as if it's a salvation
issue
the number of people when we just got an
apartment i didn't i didn't know what we
were doing with our livestreams they
sound like a beagle chasing a rabbit
oh you're just gonna if you want you
could i'll just go flush your money for
you i mean i
it was over and over and over yeah and
they're all they're all broke
but they all got expert advice on me
buying a house yes that's right
you know it's just they're just and they
do they they drive
p you people you broke people don't need
to be giving financial advice
it makes you look dumb and god help you
somebody will follow it
and just set a young couple up to be
stable
and you said it best the last thing a
young couple needs taking two new jobs
in a new town
and a new marriage is to also be
worrying about can we make this rent
payment or this this mortgage payment
this month or what's our house worth or
the plumbing broke or whatever happens
with new houses
which it always happens you know in in
ancient times the second kings in the
bible even
when a young couple got married it's
very clear
that the brand new husband did not go
out to war
in the first year he stayed home to make
a home with his wife
they didn't put brand new married
soldiers on the front lines
in ancient israel you need to get
because he knows if he goes out there
and you know it's not going to make good
decisions he's not going to make good
decisions
yeah and it's very interesting there's
something about that first year of
marriage i mean you probably know some
research on the statistics of
you know what you invest in each other
in the first year of marriage
sets a pattern for the rest of your life
that's the key is
these patterns that you adopt really
quick and it can take
years to unwind and they happen
overnight right yeah
you're both bringing you're both
bringing your old patterns into this one
pattern and you set it real fast
it takes a while to undo those things
you say or those things you do or those
annoying
man you've got to really unlearn all
that spend your time getting to know
each other here's the other thing
when you say when you do give somebody
good advice they remember it i remember
sharing i've been married almost 40
years we got married and we moved into
this too expensive a house
and it was three it was four bedrooms
there was two of us two dogs
it was ridiculous but it was nice yeah
you know and we thought we were we
thought we were
you know pretty cool and i went back i
stopped by and saw my old
uh elementary school principal evelyn
hyde
and she's like where are you living i
told her and i was like all proud and
she's like
that's dumb
[Laughter]
she's a she was the best that's the best
the world needs more evelyn's yes they
do to look at
genius 22 year olds and say that's dumb
that was dumb
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community
of believers giving you the opportunity
to create
many more verses
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
austin is with us in fort myers florida
hey austin how are you
pretty great how about you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
so i'm i've been i recently just got
married about a year ago
congratulations me and my wife are
trying to purchase a house
um so i'm just trying to get some good
advice um as well
okay what's your question she also has
she also has some student loan debt and
we're trying to figure out if this is a
good time to buy a home or pay off your
student loans pay off the student loan
okay so you have the money to pay off
the student loan
um i have i have money saved before i
got married to her
and she and it's i mean i know when we
got married it's all
it's all equal as one but it's great
that i had saved before we got married
correct but now it's hers
okay it's not it's not i have money it's
we have money now you're now
we when you get married you're french we
we
jones okay so here's the thing unto the
the old the old-fashioned marriage vows
in the book of common prayer
say in sickness and health for richer
for poorer unto thee all my worldly
goods i pledge
you don't hear that in wedding vows much
anymore
uh it's kind of anti-prenuptial it's
quite the opposite it's uh if we're
going to share life we are going to
share the money
and the problems and the good things
because you're gonna end up sharing them
all anyway
you might as well just admit it so this
is a good time to admit it and it's a
good exercise for her
to accept that her student loans are
paid off that she got before marriage
with money that you got before marriage
and that's a very real sign in your
relationship spiritually and financially
that you have combined your households
and then you start then you build your
emergency fund and then you save up for
a good down payment
yeah don't go into a house without an
emergency fund man because 100 chance
something's going to break when you buy
it
and you don't want to walk into that
house with student loan debt and
suddenly you're swimming upstream trying
to fix stuff and
make that mortgage payment let that
house be a blessing man
and there's something that snaps
in the psyche dr john that you know when
you force yourself to do an
action that reveals that there's a new
reality
yes i i it's this uh
it's a winnowing right it's this it's
it's a test moment
to where you can talk about all day long
i know this is gonna be ours that can be
ours you can hear that here
i know this is ours but but i saved it
right
yeah okay well cool pay it off right
yeah and it's it's like
it's this shaky hand signing it off when
i really do it now is when it's a real
thing yeah and i don't want to hate on
anybody i get
no no he's in heart he wasn't doing
anything wrong that's a normal process
whether you've been married a year
whether you've been married 10 years
there's people married 10 years still
talking like that oh
most 30 years 40 years with separate
checking accounts you take care of these
bills i'll take care of these bills like
roommates
even that's exactly what they are the
roommates they've never fully come
together on this deal
but when you anything where you're
changing your life you're changing a
behavior pattern
and then you have to actually do the
action yes not just discuss the theory
of the action
there's something that snaps in the old
psyche you have to step into it it calls
your bluff
and it begins to change you physically
and neurologically changes you from the
inside out and all of that austin in
your situation
is means that your marriage is already
awesome and it's about to get a little
better
yes that's what we're saying and it's
gonna be real uncomfortable for a minute
right before it gets better
there you go yeah as you write that
check you make sure your hand may shake
a little bit and then six months later
you're gonna be going
yeah but this is the woman debt-free
this is the woman i love that's
beautiful
daniel's in new york city hey daniel how
are you
daniel hello hi daniel hey dave and john
what's going on how are you
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
uh thank god um so i've been a listener
for a couple years already
you know i listen daily really keeps you
motivated and moving in the right
direction
thank you but um but yeah of course so i
set myself up i think i'm in a good spot
i have some money saved up
in the past couple years of working and
i wanted to know
how what i can do to really be setting
myself up for success
okay are you working you're in college
how old are you what's your story
i'm in college i have about a year left
okay what are you studying
business management good for you okay
what's it gonna cost to finish
um no i have a college fund that's
taking care of that and i have some
scholarships
as well so great what's it gonna cost to
finish
not sure exactly probably another
two semesters so you don't know what a
semester costs
maybe like another 25 to 50 000 here's
25 each method what the crap are you
going to school
yeah on mars
where are you going to school in the
city
is it a secret it's a secret is it a
secret school
what's the name of your school what
say it again it's not such a large
school so i'd rather not stay
okay all right it's a very small very
expensive school in new york city it's a
spy school day yes
okay well it's a secret school all right
so the um
all right so uh you think you have
enough money in the college fund and in
scholarships to finish how much money do
you have saved that you're worried about
investing
uh like 250. 250
000 yeah spy school's paying pretty good
this is pretty neat i'm way in the wrong
job i should have been what in the world
are you doing where did you get 250 000
i mean i've been working since like all
throughout high school since i'm like
14.
i worked really hard in high school and
i had like 250 dollars exactly
11. where did you what did you do i just
i
never is it a secret what you did you
were a spy in high school weren't you
and now you're in spy school
and now you're rich dude i was so
impressed we're picking on you these
numbers are bizarre
way to go well here's the thing the
standard answer here is this
and i'll stick with the standard answer
although these numbers are not standard
um congratulations you're obviously a
young stud
oh kidding aside awesome you're you got
scholarships you've made a lot of money
already i never saw 250 i could
lord that's amazing good for you so
proud for you
so your first goal is graduate you
are the secret sauce to success graduate
with no debt you think you've got that
figured out you probably do have that
figured out you probably have enough
money in your
account with your scholarships and your
college fund to do that
i really don't care if you invest 150
000 for the next one year
that is not going to change your life
going finishing this school with zero
debt and launching yourself with zero
debt into the marketplace
is going to change your life and
understanding that you are the secret
sauce here
not the interest on 250 000 for one year
dave would you recommend a 23 year old
with that kind of money
to launching and buy a house or would
you even recommend this
high school to chill yeah get out of
school because when you graduate from
school you have a high
rate of uh transition correct
you don't you often change cities you
obviously start a new job
a real job and the chances of changing
you know he probably ought to keep doing
what he's doing but
um the uh uh and it's not unusual get
married
right in that in within 18 months of
that right so
statistically not everybody you don't
have to it's not like a rule you're not
doing something wrong if you don't
there's some there's some research that
says men especially
do everything all at once right that one
year following school
and that takes some money and you
probably are going to end up in the same
city you're in
a high statistical average you're going
to end up in her city
[Laughter]
or is there any data on you take a job
right out of college
what's the chances you're still in that
job five years later
yeah very low okay that's what i would
think these days in the old days it was
but
these days you the average person has 17
jobs in their working lifetime okay
so you got the turnover but dude you're
you've done so well daniel you're going
to be all right i think you're going to
struggle through with your quarter
million dollars
yeah you're going to figure it out and
if y'all need any extra spies daniel you
know a guy
you you always wanted to be a spot i
always wanted to be a spy
when it pays like that i'm telling you
bond in high school man
i had no idea james bond was so loaded
he drank well but man
i didn't know it was a good high school
he's had a good car but we thought it
was a government car
i made i thought i was killing it making
20 bucks a lawn in high school
daniel just embarrassed me man well he
said 250 i didn't know what he meant
that's quite a goal danny for you daniel
we're we're we're having some fun buddy
but
my only because i'm jealous yeah exactly
and we're just
freaked out but yeah you did really good
man so graduate
graduate graduate graduate graduate debt
free then become an investor
then start your life don't get in too
big a hurry you're not missing out on
compound interest
by being out of the market for one year
making sure you graduate
graduate graduate debt-free you are the
secret sauce you are the best investment
you can make
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personalities my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage baby
mike and laci are here hey guys how are
you
good how are you good how are you dave
good how do we
where do you all live uh we live in
northern new york all right
very cool welcome all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free scream
you can see uh canada from our backyard
ah literally
that's how fun we are well at least it's
not russia
all right so you're not a palin are you
but go ahead
so uh how much debt have you paid off
a hundred and four thousand all right
how long did this take
one day more than two years we had to
wait for payday i'll take it
i'm going to round that down to two
years and your
range of income during that time uh we
started out at 90 000
and we went up to 172 000
and then we went down to 173 because of
the pandemic
oh yeah good gracious you doubled your
income so what kind of day uh what kind
of debt was this
uh we had five of the zero percent
promotions because we thought we were
really smart
you showed them right yeah we had my car
we had a camper
and then we each had student loans how
y'all were like normal yeah we were
paying on a deck for a house that we
didn't even live in anymore
oh that hurts yeah i was like it has to
go i don't think it really helps
and then they get real mad if you go sit
on it after you don't live there anymore
they don't like
if you park your camper that you're
paying on in the driveway right yeah in
the winter time
oh no that hurts looking out at it with
snow on top
what do you guys do for a living uh i'm
a certified professional boudoir
photographer
okay and i'm a director of case
management i'm a nurse oh very cool
good for you guys so how did you double
your incomes uh i
cranked up the work i just took on more
work and
invested in my education and just kind
of took off
wow what about you um well i've kind of
scaled the entire time in my career so
you got the opportunity to take on
overtime like crazy right yeah oh yeah
especially especially in 2020 yeah
actually during the pandemic
my business was shut down and he had to
take a 20
pay cut because the hospital wasn't you
know
having all the elective surgeries and
whatnot so yeah plus i'm salary so
there's no such thing as overtime for
sale oh i'm sorry oh my gosh
okay wow all right so what started this
journey two years ago i got you guys so
fired up
uh well i actually had heard about you
from um an educator that i followed and
i saw your your book in the thrift store
and i was like why not you know i've
spent
it's a dollar yeah it's a dollar it was
two but that's okay the cover was flashy
it caught our eye wow
good looking gown people i think dave
ramsey they think flashy yeah that's
what that's what comes to mind
exactly i think um
we've we've kind of had this concept in
our head the entire time that we've been
together
but we we call it we did like dave
ramsey light yeah
we didn't really know where we were
going or what we were doing but we knew
that um not being in debt was kind of
where we needed to be so although we've
over time we've had cards and things
like that we never carried a balance
we knew at different times that when we
had debt we had to pay it down
so we've tried over the years we just
never had a clear path how long you all
been married so
uh 17 years what so what actually in
your brain
what do you think was there an event or
a certain
thing that happened that caused you to
just flip the switch and go i'm all in
let's do this
um yeah no it just was like we i picked
the book up and i was like okay this
sounds like a good idea
you know like he had said we uh you know
we had the idea in our head
and we just didn't know where we were
going so once i read the book i was like
oh yeah this is
we just made a couple little tweaks and
like that's what we needed she read it
then i read it and we were sold and we
were like let's do this so just the
total money makeover and game on
yeah wow and then i listen to your
podcast every day we were believers
anyways prior to that we just needed
that path we needed those stories we
needed that guidance to be able to
be on the right you know right
trajectory so there was no big
drum roll moment where one of you
presented this to the other it was just
hey i'm i'm in
you're in let's let's get up well she
did it first yeah she really absorbed it
she's you know she's the reader she's
the
the studier and she kind of you know
planned this out and then kind of
brought me on board um and and that's
where we bought into
the you know the whole concept that you
know this is a plan we need to be on
love i'm definitely the nerd so i found
a calculator online and i was like we
could pay off our debt really quick
let's do this yeah and so it was really
easy to get them on board
wow congratulations i'm so proud of
y'all you're impressive thank you
very very well done very well done now
that you're professionals you paid off a
hundred
and four thousand in two years
uh what's the secret to getting out of
debt america wants to know
uh i think it was really automating um
so every time we got paid i just
automatically put the money right into a
debt account and
you know we just clicked the button we
actually didn't do the budget for a long
time until this last april when i was
like i'm bored let's do something
uh and so then once we started doing
that i was like wow we have a lot more
money now
wow you don't realize what's there until
you start like what you say crunching
the numbers and you realize it's almost
like money begets money yeah it's there
but but when you start managing your
money and you start accounting for every
penny
it seems like there just is more it
feels like more it feels like you got a
raise
absolutely and it's amazing feeling
really for that to happen like that so
yeah congratulations you guys who were
your biggest cheerleaders
um probably my parents and um you know i
have a couple
a couple friends that were you know kind
of cheering me on we'd make you know
every time i would make a big sale or
something we'd get like a cash fan and
be like yes we are you know
that much closer to paying off our
student loans or whatever we were on so
it was it was uh we did have a lot of
people around us that were really
supportive
and she's an entrepreneur she you know
didn't really
start off by herself you know knowing
what she wanted to do but i was kind of
the cheerleader behind her to say you
can do this so
i was living vicariously through her in
terms of her her entrepreneurial
spirit and it was really nice to watch
that and you know encouraging
her along the way um you know and that's
why
obviously our income increased a lot i
think we wouldn't be where we are right
now if it wasn't for the work that she
did in her business
wow the blood sweat and tears you know
building it from the ground up
um you know reading the business books
late at night and just trying to figure
out how to make things work and
she's how far are you in now five or six
years yes i've been a photographer for
13 years but i've been doing um
my business for six now congratulations
you guys how many things
in the world make me happier than
listening to a husband describing how
proud he is of his wife
yeah that's beautiful man that's awesome
thank you well done very proud of her
so how did this help your marriage uh
yeah we definitely had to
you know be on the same page and i i
think we were just competing to see who
could make more money because
you know i would do well and then he'd
get a raise and it was it was great
i think it was very exciting actually i
think it helped our marriage in terms of
that because
you know for us to do this journey and
then of course we've been trying to
inspire people along the way and
describing what this is all about we've
handed out books you know we're
we're always thinking one step ahead you
know how to how to be forward thinking
you know
getting on to those next steps um and so
that's that's how
we got us very cool and you brought the
kiddos to do the debt-free screen what
are their names and ages
uh we have andrew he's eight and we have
evelyn she is six
all right very cool well we've got a
copy of the legacy journey which is my
last book i did uh on
what happens now what are you going to
leave a legacy now change the family
tree
so give you a copy of that and take care
of you so thank you guys for making the
trip all the way from new york we're so
proud of you
you're incredible people very very well
done all right
mike and lacey andrew and evelyn from
new york 104 000 paid off in two years
making 90 to 172 to 163.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
three two one we're dead free
i love it i love it i love it i love it
that's the first one that's the first
macklemore thrift store uh debt free
scream i've heard of man that's
incredible
what what a fortuitous walk through a
thrift store man two dollar book
yeah that's a good roi on that purchase
yeah that old total money makeover for
two dollars slightly
used slightly it was shiny because
somebody spilled something on it
so uh hey but then they turned into
proselytizers and they've been buying
books and handing them out man i tried i
made out on that so i think what we
should do is start just putting
some coffee a few books in the thrift
store
i like it because it leads to more book
sales this is a new marketing plan
yes james is going to be right on that
yeah get on that james make that happen
send kelly out to the thrift stores
right now that's perfect well done you
guys
very very proud of you you guys are
incredible well that's how you do it you
work together
that you know and they kept saying over
and over they really didn't do anything
different except start paying attention
and make every dollar behave and then
every time they dialed in that much more
and made every dollar
behave they got that much more mileage
out of it and it accelerated the process
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones
triple h 825-5225
mark is with us in boston hey mark
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave really appreciate how you
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
yeah so i'll uh i'll throw a little back
story here i'm currently
an undergraduate student um full-time
enrolled
i have a full tuition scholarship i'm
also a resident advisor so i don't play
room and board either
so i actually uh i net nothing at the
end of each semester
um recently i just bought a car um i
have about
ten thousand dollars in debt on that um
there's a obviously a large push from
the left pushing for uh
student loan forgiveness so i was
wondering what your thoughts would be
on um pulling out student loans again
and transferring paying off my
car with those loans with student loans
and possibly getting the chance to
have my car loan that is now student
loan forgiven
so i'm a taxpayer and i'm supposed to
pay off your car
with your student loan forgiveness don't
you think that's immoral
yeah a little bit but at the same time
it's
um yeah a little bit it's if the
opportunity is there
um if the government's gonna be deciding
to start handing out
money left and right why not take the
yeah so um
let me tell you the the there was a book
out several years ago called millionaire
next door by a man named tom stanley who
passed away it came out in 1992.
he did a book later called the
millionaire mind the millionaire next
story studied millionaires the
millionaire mind he studied people that
had 10 million dollars deck of
millionaires
and he looked for the character he
looked for the
correlating statistical points he was a
researcher and
people that had 10 million or more
and um he found demographic similarities
he found
uh career similarities and he found 38
statistical points of reference that
indicated that they were causal
that indicated that if you had a large
number of these you would have a high
indicator that you were heading towards
10 million
or more and he listed them in order of
the
of you know the first one in other words
number one was the most often occurring
38 was the least often occurring out of
the 38 points you understand what i'm
saying
and let me tell you what number one was
fanatical levels
of integrity
you need to visit that and sit on that
because when you do not have fanatical
levels of integrity
you are missing the number one
correlating data point
towards become building wealth
versus how much can i scam the american
taxpayer out of
and get me a free car dude that's just
wrong
yeah it's just wrong
so no you should not do that a a a
really important mentor of mine posed an
important question back in my
20s and the question was this is
integrity something you can sort of have
you can mostly have
and that has just sat and sat inside me
for a long long time
because i lived some of my life thinking
yeah i mean mostly you know
and here's the thing dave
that bill's gonna come do for all of us
it's gonna come do for all of us there's
just no you you don't nobody gets rich
scamming the government the taxpayers no
it's just you don't get wealthy that way
you know you don't get wealthy trying to
you know run a welfare scam you don't
get worse you don't run
you don't get wealthy running up uh
unemployment scam you don't get wealthy
scamming the
you know hiding your grandpa's assets so
you can get a government-funded medicaid
nursing home
which is illegal as crud it's called
welfare fraud but people do it every day
and so stealing is not a part of
integrity
why do you think decca millionaires what
what's the correlation there
i don't know a lot of deca millionaires
uh
the ones that i know anecdotally align
up with that i mean
everybody knows so you know any group of
people you put them in the room and
there's there's idiots in everybody
there's a there's a jerk right there's
somebody that doesn't have integrity so
not all deca millionaires do but there's
a high correlation of that
that when they interviewed their wife
when they interviewed their kids when
they interviewed their employees when
they interviewed their competitors
in the marketplace they said you know i
always agree with that guy but one thing
about it
if he says it's raining you better get
your umbrella you know
if he says if he says he's going to
lease hell on you you better get ready
because hell's coming
you know you better whatever he says
he's going to do he's going to do and so
uh
there's fanatical levels of integrity
and and i think it's because
most things in this world move on the
speed of trust i was gonna say i think
you could probably stumble and grit and
grind
and cut and cheat your way to three
million dollars but
to get 10 you got to have other people
walking alongside you got to have
somebody else
lifting with you if they don't trust you
yeah and trust is just a it's a mammoth
thing
uh and yeah how you get trust well
you're unbelievably consistent and
you know the word integrity comes uh
from the same root word that we get the
word integer from
okay or integral okay and so the word
integer if you're a math nerd you know
that
an integer is a whole number it has no
fraction
to it it's not 1.5 it's not 1.25 it's a
whole
it's two one three it's whole
and integrity is whole the whole person
and it's not like well i don't you know
i don't cheat on my
wife but i do cheat on my taxes you know
you know you're just a freaking cheat
it's just a matter of time
before it's revealed somewhere else it's
because it's that hole
and the the interesting thing about this
is the reason i'm wearing this young man
out is
uh directly and indirectly and people in
our audience simultaneously
is that it's a choice you can grow up
being a cheat and just decide i'm done
yeah
characters in the bible jacob i'm done
jacob did it yeah he was known as the
deceiver in the bible and then he became
a man of integrity
you can just say as of today i have
integrity you can just decide
yeah you can't decide i'm beautiful you
can't decide to grow hair i've tried
but you can just decide i'm gonna have
integrity that's gonna tell the truth
i'm gonna be a man i'm gonna be a woman
that can be counted on and so i you know
i
i you know once i got all that dialed
into my head
like you know what i pay all my taxes
every stinking dime i owe
exactly we don't have a side set of
books like we don't count the cash
we count the cash the cash is part of
the profit it's taxable income
in america when you make a cash profit
on something you can hide it
but i you but the but the law says and
my integrity says when i sign that tax
return
that it's real now i hate taxes and i
don't pay a dime more
than i have to and i spend money with
accountants trying to legally
use everything in the law to not pay it
right but
once i know what's owed i it's every if
if i ever get audited come on over be a
hot knife through butter because it's
it's all right there baby i got nothing
to hide and my guess is
your heart rate runs a little lower yeah
you're sleeping you sleep at night
you know the whole thing you know i
don't have to remember what i don't have
to try to remember what i said because
whatever i said was what i said
right huh you know it's like we were
digging around in the
warehouse we closed up a warehouse this
week and they brought some of the old
files over
and i found a file in there i was going
through them this morning with my
assistant trying to figure out what to
throw away
and there's a file from 1999 with hate
mail
and um she she gets all my hate mail
anyway you know because they mail it and
comes here and so she's like
this is the same thing they say right
now they hate you for exactly the same
reason that they did in 1999
i think we need to we need to read it on
the show oh i do need to do i'll bring
the file down
next week we'll do that yeah that's a
good idea but you know
i'm unbelievably consistent i'm even
hated for the same reason next week
we're going to do an episode on my show
james of just that
40 minutes of reading letters it's going
to be fantastic we're all going to feel
better about ourselves
well we used to do read mean tweets but
now that's all there are so
it will be all you have to do is open it
nice tweets that's right because they're
the rare ones there's three of them
that's right
three twitter is troll land but you know
the
the thing is that that
once as a young guy i figured out
reading these people and understanding
these people and it became a part of my
faith walk too to tell the truth to be
the truth to to be consistent
it does get easier it's hard in the
moment
i mean he's got ten thousand dollars in
debt now yeah that might have might have
gone away if biden makes it go make
student loans go away
but um that's like fraud yeah
it it you know if you if you hide assets
so that you can get government money
yeah that's illegal
and my my challenge with the bailout
besides the fact that we don't have the
money is
dave i i didn't understand what i was
signing my wife and i signed for a lot
but at the end of the day i signed my
name on a piece of paper and said i'll
pay you back yeah
you know what i mean that's all that's
wrestled in my that's just been in me
it's old school
told you i'll pay you back i will yeah
yeah
my challenge with it is i it doesn't
bother me much it's just quit making the
stinking loans if you're gonna forgive
them
it's intellectually dishonest you plug
the hole first right
yeah that's just why are you making them
if they're so dadgum bad
stop making them and then we'll talk
about the rest of them this
is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsay personality
host of the dr john delony podcast which
is
uh unbelievably popular these days i
guess it actually is believable but
it's not i don't believe it i've got
like 11 friends
and my mom and well that started your
base and it has exceeded and they have
they have all told six people each and
so we got it going
my mom hits refresh a lot and i thought
that was just it but it's
no it's actually a thing it's more than
that you've become a thing dude
it's happened right here at ramsey we
watched it happen so
check it out if you want to hear about
life and mental health and boundaries
and relationships it's all dr john
dolone show and
you will leave a lot of things but board
will not be one of them
and so check it out we'd love to have
you there and his best-selling book
redefining anxiety as well so we're here
to help you with your life your money
your mental health questions your
relationship questions your life your
money
all of that is woven in there together
kim is with us to start off this
particular hour
in roanoke west virginia hi kim how are
you with every virginia hey kim how are
you
virginia i'm good thank you so much for
taking my call i need some education
and some advice okay i am 51 years old
my husband's 57 more debt free
except for the house we finally got our
emergency fund
fully funded which means we were able to
start our roth this week
which brought us up to 15 we owe 170 000
on the house
and my question and because i don't know
a lot about
whole life policies we have two um one
is worth twenty six thousand
cash value and one's fourteen thousand
and i want to know if we should take
those and put them
against the principle of that 170 000
and
how that works okay uh
well life insurance is a crummy place to
invest money it is not for an investment
it's for replacing
one of your incomes if one of you dies
to help the other one get along we have
terms you have enough term insurance in
place
my husband's dad is a state farm agent
he got him his
whole life policies a long long long
time ago
we have term insurance 600 000 on him
300 000 on me
so state farm yeah no that's a different
company through
through our financial advisor oh okay
okay good well um your husband's uh
dad is still living yes yes
okay he may not understand but i would
cancel those
okay he likely won't understand but he's
yeah
but that's not relevant to the
conversation this stuff's it's crap
it's absolute crap and so you're better
off to have your money going into things
that are going up in value
and that have a good rate of return and
um
you know and get the you know get the
cash value out while you can
because if you die whatever cash value
is in there
stays with the insurance company state
farm keeps it they only pay the face
amount of a policy that's how whole life
works that's one of the reasons it's
such a rip-off
so um you do want to go ahead and get
rid of that you may have some
relationship issues in the midst of
doing that but you need to get rid of it
so folks here's the way this works whole
life life insurance is roughly
20 times more expensive for the same
amount of insurance
nationally that's the averages so what
you can buy for five dollars a month in
term
cost you a hundred dollars a month in
whole life but dave it's such a great
investment
and the other 95 dollars that is not
going to insurance then
goes into an investment right and so
let's learn the rules
of the investment the first thing that
happens is the first three years of a
whole life policy
your cash value is zero so you invested
95 a month in our example for three
years and
you have nothing
that's called a front loaded financial
product if you're being kind it's called
getting screwed if you're not
then once you do get money in there and
it starts building up
the average whole life policy in this
nation today pays 1.2 percent
interest and this is a long-term
retirement plan investment which by the
way the
consumer price index was 4.2 for the
last 74 years
meaning inflation so if you're not
making at least four percent of your
money you're not keeping up with
inflation
so you're losing money when you save
money long term at one percent
that's after you lost all your money for
the first three years but after all of
that if you do it for years and years
and years and years and years
years and you finally have 20 000 in
this
40 or 50 000 whole life policies or cash
value build up
that you paid an extra 95 dollars a
month for all these years and then you
die
your fifty thousand dollar policy with a
twenty thousand dollar savings in it
that you've paid twenty times
extra per month to get pays
fifty 50 000
what happened to your 20 oh they keep it
we gifted it to the insurance company
yeah
because we're just those kind of people
we wanted a bigger shinier building in
our downtown
we needed another tower you know dave
when you first told me this several
months ago
i even got over the dismal return
what i didn't get over it's just driven
me crazy when i'm driving home by myself
they keep your money is that they go
invested at 12
and they keep the 11 gap oh yeah they
yeah because most of your shopping malls
and so forth are
financed the mortgage company on major
commercial projects is life insurance
companies
they they loan money back out into real
estate as a mortgage company
and make you know eight ten twelve on it
wherever in there and so uh
but aside from that so you have a
banking system where
you bought term insurance for five
dollars you put 95 dollars into a
savings program
that for the first three years they keep
your money after that they pay you 1.2
percent and when you die they keep your
savings account
now what kind of idiot would have a
savings account like that none
but of course it's never explained to
you that way by those people because
they sell this crap
so there's only two people that sell
whole life life insurance ignorant
people that don't understand it
who are actually good kind sweet people
they're just ignorant
because that's exactly how it works or
crooks
because if you understood that and you
sell it anyway you're crook
by definition and so um
that means that sweet little lady's
sweet little father-in-law i just called
him a crook but oh well
or are ignorant he's more than likely
just ignorant though
most of those guys i know in that world
they're this to make sure they see that
money they'll make sure they mainly sell
they mainly sell homeowners and car
insurance
and so then that you know their company
has whole life and they they get them
tied up into this and they make good
money
because you get paid in the insurance
world you get paid on premium and so if
the premium's 20 times more your
commission's 20 times more
so of course they're going to go oh i
think that's really good stuff
you know but no one in the entire
financial community
not a single person anywhere in the
financial world today recommends cash
value life insurance
except people that sell it
none of the rest of us none of us that
have you know that are independent
people in the investment world you know
they tell you get
you you do need life insurance but you
need to get term insurance people
anywhere else
any kind of study you do any kind of
formal academic study you do anything
unless it's from the whole life world
unless it's from the people who sell it
they don't tell you to buy it because
it's absolutely the payday lender of the
middle class
is there any data that shows that people
buy that more than term
oh yeah they buy a lot more than that i
feel like everyone i know has whole life
yeah
and the reason you know why they buy it
more in terms because they're sold more
pushed more than
the term yeah i mean until until 15 20
years ago
term insurance and nobody talked about
it hardly this was like this was the
you know but if you go into every major
city in america that in the skyline is
banks intern
and life insurance companies i wonder
how that happened santa claus didn't
build those buildings you did people
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show common sense
for your dollars and cents teaching
people to live
on less than they make a concept
congress can't grasp
lydia is with us in columbia missouri
hey lydia how are you
fine thank you how are you doing today
better than i deserve how can we help
you
um my husband and i are currently
renting
and our rent and spies roughly by july
this year
we've been planning to buy our own home
and we started listening to your program
less than two or three months
and we want to buy our own home because
our kids are here to join us we are
immigrants
i joined my husband about two years ago
in the pandemic
or before the pandemic and i started
working not long ago
our income for the year
it's about 150 160 my husband makes over
100
and i make about 30 000.
we have car loans my husband has student
loans
we have irs debt our total debt is 125.
uh our question is you've been here he's
been here
three years or you've been here three
years i have been here two years he has
been here 20 years
20 10 10.
okay i was thinking man he got car debt
and irs debt pretty quick
okay wow okay so
now where which uh which country are you
immigrating from
uh ghana africa wonderful and uh
is this a permanent citizenship or green
card or what
i am on green card he's permanent
resident okay
all right wonderful so you'll be able to
get your citizenship then right
yes yes wonderful awesome well welcome
we're glad you're here
all right and what do you guys do for a
living um
he's a nest and i'm also a nurse as well
but i am a medical assistant he's unless
in the
fight field gotcha and how old are your
children
our son is 21
daughter is eight 15. our two little
ones
10 and eight and they're all in africa
one is here one is my step my husband
had a child out
with someone when he was here without me
and then i have
a natural fat i have two kids he has two
back home
but we both are out of our first
marriages so
we we have been together less than five
years i understand
okay and the um
so you're you're you could rent a home
for the children that would live
in your home if they were to move here
correct
yes okay that's what you need to do you
need to get out of debt
first build your emergency fund of three
to six months of them expenses
second and then then start saving
to buy a home when you buy a home with
all this debt hanging around your neck
and with no emergency savings
the home will end up being more of a
curse than a blessing it is not
a uh it is it is home ownership when
you're broke is a bad thing it will get
you it will bite you
um and so you've got you've got good
incomes
uh he has had some bad he's developed
some bad american habits with money
i hear them in the mistakes he's made
you may have participated in a couple of
those but you got car debt you got irs
debt you got some other things you need
to clean up here
because that's that's a mess and then
save
your emergency fund for a rainy day and
then
and then do this so what i want to do is
i want to help you with this because i'm
inspired by your story
we have a class called financial peace
university we have a budgeting app
called every dollar
the premium version of every dollar in
financial peace university are all
included in what's called
ramsey plus a one-year membership
to that to be able to watch those videos
go through this
financial class you and your husband do
that together
obviously we charge a hundred dollars
for all of that per year
if i give it to you as a gift will you
promise me that you and your husband
will do
everything in there yes you will
i think you might so you hold on and
i'll give it to you kelly will pick up
and we'll get you signed up
um that's pretty cool that's super cool
and i love how you framed that you've
picked up some bad american habits
you don't do that in ghana that's hey
man you don't have irs debt and car debt
in ghana
no it's it's the truth right it's the
truth it's a
it's a cultural thing i mean there's
there are countries that do the same
stupid butt stuff we do
australia they're about as you know uk
you know england about as stupid as we
are on stuff like this
or dumber in some cases but uh as a
culture but
um you know you can observe these things
in different cultures the way people
handle money the way they see money
it has a lot to do with a lot of
different factors economic factors and
other things but
you know what's interesting is if they
get their act together they have a
higher probability of becoming wealthy
than someone that's born here
why do you think that is i think they
believe that it's a land of opportunity
and some of us aren't sure
we just don't believe it anymore we're
waiting on somebody else to do it and
that that
all they wanted was a chance a place
that they could do it and they just see
fields upon fields to go be killed right
it's the uh the land of opportunity not
the land of
and entitlement they see it that way
they think the statue of liberty is real
and um i do because i'm an old-fashioned
american softy
some of the coolest most inspirational
folks i've i've been around in my
in my in my educational career was
international students who'd come over
and say
you're telling me i can get a law degree
here you tell me i can go to med school
you're telling me i can go to walmart
and they have seven kinds of game
on yeah let's do this man this is the
land of abundance yeah
yeah gift upon gift upon gift two aisles
of cookies
yeah what do you mean you gotta be
kidding me yeah it's it's real
john's in arlington virginia hey john
welcome to the ramsay show
yes sir thank you um thank you
hi david hi john hi how can we help
uh so i have a question i'm on a baby
step six
of your book um i have uh
network is about one 1.8 million way to
go
free all right thank you um
i didn't think it happened uh so network
i'm debt free um definitely have an
emergency fund
my mortgage is uh 381
000 left on it and
i'm considering there's out of my
brokerage accounts
um there's one fund that has about 314
000 in it
and i'm wondering if i should sell that
to pay off
my mortgage um it's returning about 13
percent
and how old are you
okay where'd it go did you uh did you
inherit any of this 1.8 million
um i inherited nine thousand nine
thousand dollars
yeah that's the greatest answer
so you did what's been your income
through your working life here
um so when i was 20
it was down like somewhere some years 50
dollars and
to 100 to a couple thousand i had uh
what's been your best year what'd you
make your very best year ever 160
okay what's your career field
uh and uh software consulting way to go
i'm so proud of you man awesome man so
here's the way you answer the question
there's a
an old thing from the harvard investment
newsletter that's called
sunk cost analysis and you just reverse
engineer your question and it'll answer
it for you
if your home was paid off and you did
not have this investment com
brokerage would you go borrow on your
paid for home
and put 300 000 in a brokerage account
no same thing
every day that you don't pay this off
you borrowed it again
yeah so what that question does though
is it also causes you you're telling me
about the 13
rate of return and all that crap so
that's the math
side of your brain the other side of
your brain called your heart
is where you measure risk and when i
suggested that you borrow on your paid
for home
it kind of puts your stomach in your
throat a little bit and that means that
you all of a sudden started
measuring the risk of this you're not
going to go bankrupt and you're not
going to foreclose down you're worth 1.8
million dollars you've done you've done
it dude
you're good but this is just a
measurement of peace when your head lays
on the pillow at night pay off your
house today sir
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure talk just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
thank you for joining us america dr john
deloney is my co-host today here on the
air
uh you can add hope to your inbox hope
to your inbox with ramsey newsletter
whether you're on baby step
one two three four five six or seven
it's packed with actionable
guidance on up-to-date ways to save
money stay on a budget invest smarter
give more every week we walk with you as
you tackle debt
as you build your savings plus you'll
never miss the latest
articles shows products from ramsey
solutions of course it's free
you can subscribe to the ramsey
newsletter today at ramseysolutions.com
newsletter our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
the promo code is ramsey all right
today's question comes from
robbie in california at age five i
started piano lessons and five years
later i got a job playing at a
restaurant on weekends
i was paid 60 bucks a night plus tips
my dad said that since i was a minor he
would save the money for me
when i started college and asked for the
funds i learned all the money was gone
i know the account had over eight
thousand dollars in it
how do i move on from the trauma of this
and develop a healthy relationship with
money
i don't think the relationship problem
here is with money
i think you got to say what your dad did
sucks
and there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and then you got to move on um
i'd add one more sentence what he did
sucks he sucks yeah he stole it from his
kid
what a scumburger stole from his kid
and let me tell you it'll just tell you
when i say that everybody goes yeah
but when this young man hears me say
that or you say that it's hard for him
to hear it's hard to hear your dad
is a bad guy oh yeah your mom's a bad
lady because we jump in and want to
defend him
well i mean it's just it's just that's
it's against our nature to think that
the person that's supposed to take care
of you screwed you over yeah
but you got you got to say it i often
tell people to write it down and put a
period into that sentence
yeah and then you got to feel it and it
hurts
and then you got to go make a decision
what you're gonna do next yeah
and so you know what are your takeaways
from this
you how do you defeat the
emotional scars and trauma you have to
intellectually get above them
and uh then you feel them yeah you got
to feel them
yeah but getting above them is it's not
a pr it's not a money problem it's a dad
problem it's a dead problem
and so what do you walk away from this
learning uh well hey
you're good at the piano uh people will
pay you for it
yeah uh b you uh you know you have the
ability to make money and save money
works hard
yeah you got a good work ethic i mean 10
years old he's at the pianos i'm reading
that right five plus five yeah
yeah and so um uh uh
don't trust your dad with money yeah
we're not gonna give him any money yeah
i'm not gonna
trust him with much anything really yeah
um you know just uh
five minutes of our time maybe but i'm
not not gonna leave my kid there yeah
either uh you can't trust him stealing i
don't know what else i can trust him
with so i mean
he be there with my kid but not leave my
kid there by myself by himself so
um i wouldn't um not tell this is not so
something
some kind of noticeable change in the
old man's life because he's crook
yeah um then uh the other thing is
is that you probably learned a lesson
that you do want to learn and that is
you don't trust other people to take
care of your money now when you're 10
you're supposed to
yeah he's a child but but you can take
that away and go you know when i'm 40
i'm not going to let someone
take care of my money blindly that's
right i'm going to always be involved
i'm going to always know where my money
is
i'm always going to understand it um no
one's got like
power of attorney so you know i'm in
nashville we're in nashville and
over the years i've become friends with
a lot of uh
folks in the music business they get
scammed they just and
the stories of the guys
that are you know 60 70 years old and
how they got scammed
when they were making big hits because
they turned everything over it's like an
athlete
and they knew this guy yeah and i loved
him and he hung out with my kids and my
family
and 100 million dollars later he took a
lot of my money yeah
i don't have any money because i turn it
over to him like this kid turn it over
to his dad
you have to do that when you're ten you
don't have to do that when you're adults
so it's a good it's a good takeaway and
that's not being bitter or that's not
being
toxic or something you know i don't
trust anymore because of my father no
you just don't
you know it's your job to manage the
money and understand what it's doing you
can help
get advice from people but you can't get
a babysitter for your money so there's
been some
i've been doing a lot of reading on
trauma the last few years dave and
um there's two guys dr peter levine and
another guy named dr bessel vanderkolt
they have a description of trauma that
was transformative for me
and it was it's less about the issue
and more about your body's response in
the present to that issue
so what i would tell this young man is
when he's about to do something related
with money and his heart starts racing
just stop for a second and acknowledge
oh my body's trying to take care of me
and then you can say i'm good i
appreciate your body taking care of me
but i know what i'm doing now or i've
got trust here or i've dug into this
account or i'm
and what you want to do is make peace
with your body in the present cause it's
just trying to take care of you and it
will take care of that little 10 year
old kid
for the rest of your life if you don't
acknowledge it but we spend
so much time trying to replay what has
already happened try to edit that story
you can't edit the fact your dad stole
your money what you can do
is learn to make peace with your body
moving forward that's interesting your
body
reacts as if the same event is happening
again
yes over and over it remembers to warn
you that it could be happening again
and that's why it's a warning mechanism
all day every day
and we even will fall into similar
relationships to people who hurt us in
the past
because our body wants to correct it and
fix it and we'll end up in the same
situation
over and over look i remember when we
were i was a little kid we were coming
home from my grandmother's uh
several mini like a 10 hour drive and uh
we came across the top of this hill two
lane road and stopped because the guy
was turning left in front of us
guy came over the hill and plowed in the
back of us i mean knocked us
in the neck to total the car wow it was
a bad
car wreck and um it
i that was 50 years ago
and when somebody gets up on my bumper
from behind now your heart takes off
still feeling it takes off that's right
that's the same thing and so there's a
century there's a little part of your
brain that's
is going to scan your environment
forever
until you say oh there it is i'm good
i'm in a big raptor now right yeah i'm
good yeah i'll win this exchange
yeah yeah but it's just like oh i want
to get one of those old people bumper
stickers like get off my butt you know
kind of thing
get off my lawn you know yeah that kind
of thing and uh it's just but it's all
it's that it's associated with that
trauma your body remembers that
the name of the book is the body keeps
the score right and so
when think about when you uh like when
you're you know these guys are called up
in their second marriage but their first
wife
blew all the money and stole everything
and so they have trouble trusting the
new wife and so dave we are in a culture
that is so obsessed with new information
and we can shove it all in a frontal
lobe new facts but that part of our
brain that's looking for threats is
still running and running
lizard brain is real always running
until you make peace with
she walks in holding the checkbook and
you go
you gotta go hey she's different she's
new she i trust her she ain't got the
same name i trust her that's right i
trust her she looks totally different
yeah right and your body will begin to
go okay cool just want to make sure
that she's not a threat and once you
make peace with your body man that's
when your body re
you receive this healing from this
trauma you know that's what happens when
people get their emergency fund
that's exactly right they've been living
on the edge for so long that every
stinking little thing was a crisis
everything i mean every hangnail is a
crisis when you're broke right
i mean every little dinky 50 thing is a
crisis when you're broke but when you
got ten thousand dollars in the bank
it's an inconvenience it's annoying it's
just an annoyance
but when your emotions still go oh god
oh god and we hear about people who get
out of debt and they say
i can't spend now that's it yeah because
they've got a part of their brain saying
you will never spend again because we
remember what happened last time yeah
and you got to make peace with it
yeah and that's when that's that's why
you're coaching you can retrain it
because i mean
it requires it requires intellectually
getting above it that's right
and going wait facts are my friends as
you always say yeah
and so like you know but you can't you
can't steamroll your feelings with you
guys
i mean like sharon when we went broke
she was terrorized
by us being broke yep and so anytime we
do anything that feels like the stuff we
used to do
like we might the alarm sets off and
it's like whoa
chill we've got money there's lots of
zeros and comments
we could just burn that much in the
middle of the floor nobody will care so
it's okay it's okay and she
okay she has to have to revisit it
that's very interesting the human body
is extraordinary at taking care of us
wow this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christy wright is all about equipping
women to make money doing what they love
one of the ways she does that is through
the business boutique
academy her exclusive online training
group
for women with businesses having a
business can be overwhelming it can be
lonely but it doesn't have to be
with the right training the right
support there's nothing you can't
do so whether you have a business or
side hustle ladies if you're looking for
to use your passion and skills to start
a business and make extra money
christy will guide you every step of the
way
enrollment for the academy closes
tonight we only have open enrollment
twice a year because we want everybody
to be in the same
in the same groups moving through the
process and uh only twice a year don't
miss your opportunity to get
it closes tonight at 8 pm central time
join the academy at ramseysolutions.com
academy and become part of the
incredible community of women
who are making money doing what they
love
alex is in santa clara california hi
alex how are you
good sir thank you for taking my call
how are you better than i deserve what's
up
so my parents are what you might call
rock stars mom's a teacher dad's a cop
and they are
multi-millionaires just from doing all
your stuff
which means that when i went to college
i went to this real
fancy expensive school and they were
able to cashflow the whole thing
i i'm 24 now i can't help but feel like
i
you know i want to pay them back somehow
but i can't just cut them a check you
know
it's not like they're going to care
about that so you know what
kind of things can i do as a son you
know to honor the gifts that they've
given me and pay them back somehow
get married and have babies and be a
good husband don't be an idiot
yeah you don't you don't give them they
don't want money they don't need money
uh let me tell you i got three kids that
are successful
uh have great marriages strong followers
of jesus
that they're they're experts in their
fields uh
they're they're very giving and generous
they're good moms and dads
and they bring the grand babies over to
see papa dave
i don't need anything else from them
dude that's everything that's the best
way they can pay me back don't be
screw-ups
is it really that simple it really is
hey alex and i'll tell you i'll add one
more
um i can't believe it took me this long
to do this
as i was leaving my home state to move
to nashville
um i took a detour i drove about three
hours out of the way
and i i called my dad and said hey would
you like to meet for coffee as i'm
leaving
the state he said sure and i had a
moment to look him in the eye over
coffee
and i just said hey i need you to know
something you did a great job
and i'm so glad i'm your son and
that was an exchange that i should have
had 20 years ago 15 years ago 10 years
ago
man you can't pay the light bill with
that but i think my dad
he walked about six inches taller after
that and i think every dad wants to hear
from their kids
i'm grateful for you and man as a 24
year old
your roi is money how can i pay you back
man letting them know yeah i'll tell you
grateful for your if your dad
if your dad is your hero tell him to his
face give him a hug
a front hug front hug front cut your dad
don't be weird about it do it and you
know and every so and every so often
just
go you know if you want to spend some
money uh you know
buy a couple airline tickets and go on a
blank trip whatever it is you do hunting
trip golf trip
i don't care and that kind of stuff i i
you know
my sons and i and uh my my son
son-in-law's dads we all went on a big
golfing trip this summer all together
and that was that was more fun than i
can think of doing anything so those
kinds of things
i have breakfast every tuesday morning
with my son who is one of our senior
vice presidents here and runs a big
portion of this company and
um he and i have breakfast here every
morning every tuesday morning seven
o'clock if i'm in town he's in town
and um you know we talk about everything
uh business kids everything all of them
down and it's just
that that stuff is more important dude
than you buying them a thingy
but here's the thing the fact that alex
at 24
is thinking about the character part
how can i let these two important people
know that i love them
tells me he was raised right yeah beyond
the fact that his parents didn't make a
ton of money but they still figured out
how to be millionaires
so schoolteacher and a cop that's right
yeah you're not making a ton of money in
that house
and i've lived with a schoolteacher and
a cop but
they taught this guy integrity and don't
guys life is a mist
it's a vapor i've never ever sat with
somebody who said
you know what i told my kid i loved him
too much i told my dad i loved him too
much
say it again and again and again cat's
in the cradle and a silver spoon right
all right kevin in spokane washington
hey kevin how
are you i'm
but i deserve dave good how can we help
well i have a question and i mean uh i
mean to the gist of it there's a lot of
details to it but the gist is
i've been working on lawn care for a
long time and i've as
most guys in the industry have thought
about going off on my own start my own
business and
my wife and i kind of came to that
decision over this last winter and
and we're kind of getting there so i
guess my real question is like
should i should i do it the slow way
debt-free where you know i
every i getting another couple customers
every year and i save up and i buy
equipment and then i
do it that way or i mean we both really
decided to do this full-time that if i
should take a business loan and get the
equipment i need to really get started
uh you know beginning yeah how long have
you been listening to this show
hi kevin i'd like to introduce you to my
friend dave ramsey how long you been
watching the show
well yes i mean long story short i
actually know
that's a simple question dude how long
have you been listening to the show
uh about a month okay that's cool and so
you've listened about 10 or 15 episodes
or something okay that's fine
but if you've been listening for two
years it's a different answer so uh
it's not as gentle and so um
we teach people not to borrow money
because the shortest distance between
where you are in wealth
is debt-free right and so
um i started this business as 350
million dollars this year off a card
table in my living room
and every year we poured money back into
it and grown it organically with organic
cash flow we've never borrowed a dime
um and uh you know so lots of times we
didn't go do something or buy something
because we were investing back into
ramsey
and growing ramsey and it's worked out
well for us so
um you can do the same thing here so you
start with the best equipment you can
get with the cash you have
and you work like a crazy man because
equipment is called overhead
yeah and you know you so you always want
to limit
overhead in business you don't go buy
the
the guys in the loan business that have
the biggest fanciest tractors
are the ones that make the least money
well that's the point and uh you know if
you go up on a construction site
and there's seven pickups sitting there
and there's three brand new ones that
look like they're off a chevy commercial
going through a mud puddle
and there's two beat up ones the guys
with the two beat up ones are
millionaires
the other two twerps can't make their
payments friday
and this is how life works so that's
what you do here you buy
the least equipment that'll get the job
done uh and
as you make more and more and more money
your equipment will be better and better
that's fine and more and more equipment
and you can run more than one crew
and all that kind of stuff the good news
is you know the business
well enough that you're confident that
you can grow it
that's good and so but you can
the good news about lawn care is you can
start it with very little money
uh and you probably have the cash to buy
that first tractor and little trailer
and little pickup to pull it around
and one weed eater and get her done baby
i'd love to see him put a
price everything out some good used
equipment get a number
and then sit down with his wife and say
let's go berserker mode
for nine months 12 months get that
number and get this number yeah and then
you slow down a little bit but i want
you to go bananas and get that
and just not work or if it's two
thousand dollars and you got two
thousand dollars and you wanna dump it
in there and go do it get after it right
go get it if you got the two thousand
dollars laying there and but you don't
need twenty thousand dollars to do this
no
people just overbuy to get going you
don't well you're gonna buy the wrong
stuff and it's gonna be different and
you know
i mean the computer world god man you
know how fast our computers are out of
date as soon as we unpack them out of
the box
that's kind of the new thing you buy
this whole shipment of computers
you get them up you open them all you
tear off that little
piece of cellophane and then you just
close them and put them back in the box
and yeah they usually
ship them to somebody else already done
you know it's unbelievable
so i mean i can't tell you how many
times we've replaced computers in 30
years of running this business
wow i mean we just and they're just
they're dust
they're a door stop you know but
my dad's still using that same honda
lawnmower he's had for 111 years
well i mean equipment is equipment it's
overhead and keep your overhead down if
you're going to win in business
i think you're going to do great kevin
and i think you need to go do it but you
do it with cash brother
thank you for calling in that puts this
hour of the ramsey show
in the bugs
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsieshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today
he's the host of the very popular dr
john in dalloni podcast
the popularity is going uh up and to the
right it's hockey sticking the numbers
are amazing
so if you want to hear a really
entertaining show about life
and uh people's um questions about
relationships and so forth he's there
and he's here today to help you as well
the phone number is triple eight eight
two
five five two two five speaking of calls
for dr john caleb's with us in austin
texas
hi caleb how are you good better than i
deserve how about you guys
just the same sir how can we help
figured
uh well i'm calling on behalf of my
amazing wife
her and her mom had a falling out about
probably about three years ago
and i'm sorry say that again how long
ago
probably about three years ago three
years ago okay yeah
and it's still pretty uh pretty hectic
um and so my what does that mean
what does hectic mean uh it's not it's
not a good relationship
um we so we had our son who just turned
nine months
uh they met once and our
the kind of the rules we have is not
allowed at our house and my son's
our son's not allowed over there and
it's it's just it's weighing heavy on my
wife
um so what do you feel i need to draw
that's a hard boundary why'd you feel
the need to draw that boundary
it's it's uh it's just a cancerous
person i guess to say that be more
specific you're talking pretty vague be
specific
something happened that said you cannot
do that
is a danger to your child yeah uh well
just the environment
uh her boyfriend is not uh not
the best man in the world um she's just
she's very negative she's always
heard our marriage would laugh and tell
people we're not going to laugh when my
wife got pregnant
and said uh you know that i wasn't going
to stick around
okay and we had a miscarriage and she
just blew it off and
my wife just recently asked her to uh if
they could go to counseling and try and
fix it
and she was just like uh all things
about it and it's just
i mean it's just to me my kind of view
is if
if the thought of being around someone
stresses me out i just don't even want
to deal with that
that's easier said than when it's your
mom and yeah
and your your your wife has a picture in
her head
of this new baby and her mom's a part of
that
and she had to draw boundaries for
whatever reason i still don't fully get
it but she had to draw some boundaries
that doesn't include her so she's gonna
agree i'm trying to understand just as a
guy i'll let john talk a minute but but
so your your mother-in-law's uh series
of offenses are that she's a jerk
uh yeah and well i mean she done
something other than has she done
something other than just been a jerk to
your wife uh
no no like physical harm nobody i mean
is
she just like nasty and kind of mean
snarly snarly yeah and i mean there's a
lot of uh
ethical things that have gone on with
like uh
finances and stuff like that that i
don't want to air out right
um well like she stole from your wife
uh well from uh her father okay
she's just a person of no character
right yes
okay like so she only will talk to my
wife when her boyfriend's out of town
and then
when her boyfriend comes back she
doesn't respond to anything
so what's the challenge is your wife
just struggling with just putting a
period at the end of that relationship
and moving on
yeah it's just yeah it eats her up
inside yeah
and that's where i'm calling them that
and like i'm just trying to
you know i guess the man to me is just
like well you know
so long and for her it's harder and i'm
just trying to figure out yeah it's her
mom
yeah that's her mom yeah you got to
honor that don't go don't get in the
trap of talking bad about her mom
get in the trash supporting her and
loving her
at some point she's gonna have to make
the decision she's gonna have to put a
peer at the end of that sentence her
mom's never gonna do it with her
because if she would you wouldn't be in
the situation the first place so your
wife's gonna have to decide to grieve
this loss and then start creating a new
picture that's gonna include
her baby you and whoever else but not
mom
and your wife's can do that on her own
terms in her own time
and that's frustrating and annoying if
you're a husband who loves his wife and
doesn't want to see her hurt but any
time there's a separation from a mom
like this it's
just going to be hurt yeah it's going to
be hard
yeah especially let me throw out
something um
the secret to happiness is low
expectations
yeah and so um
if uh if
her mother had a
i'll just make up something i don't know
something where let's say she had
alzheimer's
okay and when people get alzheimer's
they generally either become
much nicer than they used to be or much
meaner than they used to be
um my mother-in-law got alzheimer's and
uh
bless her soul she got nicer and um
uh and kept feeding the dog until the
dog got fed fat i mean it was it was
almost humorous and so
because she forgets she fed the dog yeah
so if you had someone like that
you would not we were never looked at
sharon's mom when she was going through
that and said
we we lowered our expectations of her
because she was deficit
does that make sense yeah no that makes
more i mean
my expectations i don't think you do
anyway yeah and i think your wife still
has high mom
expectations of a woman who can't
deliver
yeah and so if she lowered her
expectations and just said pretend like
mom has alzheimer's
and she's a little nutty because she's a
little nutty dude
the woman you just described is like
oscar the grouch
yeah and she's really not it she's
really not got her crap together
mentally
this woman doesn't but i can see the
challenge between
someone with alzheimer's and saying this
person's got i know but i'm saying if
you if you if you're
i'm talking about his wife if she
said instead of hoping mom is going to
be all
super moms oh she's never going to be i
know instead said let's treat her as if
she's deficit because she is
gotcha if you and you just go oh that's
just my crazy mother this is just your
mother
it's just my crazy mother that's just my
crazy mother yeah i mean and then you
don't
then you don't get all tore up about it
because she the reason my the girl's
getting all tore up about it she keeps
thinking mom's gonna come through she's
got
she's got this picture am i wrong um
yeah but i think i think that
i think that that having lower
expectations isn't gonna make her feel
good she's still gonna have to be
she's still gonna have to grieve that
thing that mom's never gonna come
through like that i don't disagree with
that yeah
but i'm saying if every one of these
conversations it's like
my mom did it again well what did you
expect yeah
yeah yeah yeah if you if the
rattlesnake's gonna bite you right
that's it
the stinking snake bites so don't be
when they start
you know when that little tail starts
wiggling and making that little noise
you just get back you know
caleb let me ask you this are you in a
place have you all backed yourselves
into a corner with an either or that was
a little bit over the top or do you feel
good about it
um and i'll ask you this i know a lot of
first-time parents who
who make these big declarations you
can't come into my home unless you've
you've showered in lysol and wash your
hands and by third kid you know the
kid's walking in with a handful of dog
do and nobody cares right
have you all first kitted this situation
where you have
you've made these declarations yeah and
i don't know
my mindset is if you have to hide seeing
my son then
why like why why are we even going to be
around that type of person
no disagree with you yeah well
yeah it's the bottom line is there's a
lot of heartbreak for your wife
it's very hard for her um crazy mom's
just gonna be crazy
you're looking at it very like ah that's
what it is and
it's just it's it's her mom you can't
take that loose
that there's still that umbilical cord
in the spiritual world be gentle with
your grieving man i'll send you a copy
of henry cloud's book
called boundaries he's a friend of
john's and mine and it's a world-class
book on this subject hold on i'll send
you a copy of it
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five when it comes to
making big money or
life moves like buying a home or getting
married or having a baby
it's likely the last thing on your mind
to make sure you have the right
insurance coverage
i get it big changes have a lot of
details
but what would be even more overwhelming
is to find yourself in a situation where
you or your family
are in the hole because you were not
covered if not having the time or energy
is what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance coverage
use one of our endorsed local providers
their independent agents find you the
best coverage
at the best price your car homeowners
insurance
as an example they will shop and get you
the best deal typically save you over
700
over what you're paying now a year all
you got to do is text the word insurance
233 789 text insurance
233-789 rodney's
in rochester minnesota hi rodney how are
you
good yourselves better than i deserve
what's up
hey um just recently been listening to
you
um got a couple questions on
where i'm at with my job being a union
member
we have what um you know everyone knows
there's a pension and we also have an
annuity
and i've been in the trade for seven
years now um they send us statements
now listening to you i'm kind of picking
apart when my statement comes and what
they're investing our money into good
i'm kind of break
kind of to break it down uh you
recommend 15
um last year alone and made a hundred
and like 111 000 so a little over 15 000
a year
and hours worked last year out of you
know our package they take six dollars
and fifty cents an hour
put it into that annuity and i'm you
know getting pretty close to that
fifteen percent
now do you count that as my 15
do i need to go out and start anything
else because i have my pension which
we have a great pension and the annuity
i'm just wondering where i should go
from there and i also looked on the
statements they have things like
you know they put some of our money into
bonds but they have like the mid cap
good growth stocks and
you know everything you talk about but
they also give you the option on this
website that we can change
what we'd like and i wonder if i find
like uh
you know smart investor pro and he gets
inside
my annuity can he break that down into
just strictly
um the mutual funds alone is that
something
so let me make sure i understand exactly
i think i do but let me make sure
your pension of course you're putting
nothing in their funding that
your annuity is coming out of your check
you are putting it in but it's mandatory
yes sir okay and it amounts to almost 15
percent and you have
choices in there that you can do and so
that's much like a
person in corporate america having a
401k
all right and so you have them you only
you have a mandatory
money that you're putting in do they
match the annuity as well or they just
do the pension
just uh pension perfect okay does the
annuity have the option of being a roth
i have not asked okay so first thing i
want to do is find out if it's a roth
and then the next thing um the you can
get in touch with the smart investor pro
they make their money the smart investor
pros when they sell you a mutual fund
and put it into like your roth ira or do
a 401k rollover or something like that
so helping you pick your annuity over at
the union makes them zero
they might do it anyway as a favor
because you're a dave ramsey listener so
you could ask one of them
they probably would do it just so they
could help your wife or help your kids
or your grandpa or whatever later
that kind of a thing but they're not
they're not actually going to make money
on that transaction
obviously that's a union transaction but
they might do it so
let's kind of talk through for a second
though that you said mid cap
i'm guessing they have mid cap they have
small cap they have
uh bonds uh they they probably have
large cap
or something like that does this does
that sound right you nailed it
you bet okay well let's talk through and
i'll explain to you what they
are and you can put percentages in each
one correct
yes i can okay we teach people to put
money in four types of mutual funds
growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international
and let's just have a little class here
on what this stuff is because it's good
for the listeners all across america to
hear while i'm talking to you okay
so okay uh cap means capitalization
means this money the company has large
cap
is big companies huge big dinosaur
companies if you were to look in that
large cap fund you would see names like
alcoa
general motors big old honkin
dinosaurs that move slow and are
predictable and steady
okay
small cap is quite the opposite it's the
rowdy kids
all right it's the brand new startups
the tech boys
some of the healthcare startup things uh
the brand the companies haven't been
around a long time
it's going to make a lot more money but
lose a lot more money it's going to be
wild child
of the of the mix you're following me
yes
because they're the small companies
they're brand new so they're more
volatile
or they're or they're just rowdy
whatever they i mean they could be in a
rowdy industry
whatever they're volatile mid cap guess
what that's goldilocks that's right in
the middle the porridge that's just
right
okay and so that's kind of you know
that's that's like your uh
home depot or mcdonald's
or you know uh i don't know
uh you you might find uh facebook in
there
you might find some stuff like that
those are big companies but they're not
old stodgy companies they still have
some life to them they're still kind of
they're kind of in the middle you know
they're like it's like the young
kid that's wild the middle ager and the
older guy kind of thing almost
uh in terms of their behavior and their
risk patterns
uh and so your large cap is
much like a growth and income that i'm
telling you your mid cap
is much like a traditional growth fund
your small cap
is much like an aggressive growth fund
do you have anything that sounds like
international or foreign
yes i those are on there as well they
have they list
well you know i've i've heard you run
through them and uh you know
put a few your youtubes and i looked on
my sheet and those are all on there but
they're not
split exactly 25 25
five percent okay are the large cat is
the large cap a
group of funds or one fund that is large
gap
uh it be a group there's multiple okay
so you have to pick like one whole thing
and being that is that what they're
telling you
um you know i don't know i wish i had
that [ __ ] that's okay i'm just i'm just
i'm trying yeah yeah it's it sounds like
if if
like mid cap is like 10 different funds
in there i just and you have to pick
one of them i'd pick that one okay
because
because it's right down the middle okay
and it spreads it across those 10 funds
and just forget it all right that's like
a
buying an s p 500 funds fund almost like
yeah about like buying an index fund
i wouldn't want you in the wild child
with everything i'd love to have some
over in there though
so if you could put 25 large cap 25
small cap 25
mid cap and 25 international
that would give you the mix we're
talking about and i think we're done for
the day you know i mean that's that's
going to get you there but i'm not sure
that that's what they're allowing you to
do here i can't tell
whether they're grouping these things if
you pick a single fund out of the large
cap
pick the best one the one that's got the
best track record over 10 or more years
do
a single fund out of the mid cap pick
the best one the one that's got the best
track record over 10 to 25 years
same thing in the small same thing the
international and you put those four
funds together out of those
four different categories now you've got
a portfolio like we talk about like i
personally do with my 401k
john does too here at our company and so
but that that's these these names
tell you what they are so teach me what
an annuity is i hear that a lot
an annuity is technically an insurance
company product a savings account with
an insurance company
okay this is a variable annuity that's
funded with mutual funds
a fixed annuity is a it sucks a fixed
annuity
is like a cd but at an insurance company
it's gonna pay two three percent and
they're gonna take the cap
and and but the annuity wraps around the
money and keeps it
warm from taxes like being in a 401k so
it's just a different product under a
different bank
exactly but you but inside of a variable
annuity you can have all these different
options we've been talking about okay
and so it sounds like they've got a
fairly good offering it's a broad really
great yeah
if you can just weed through the weeds
and figure out what to do with it
so yeah you could check a smart vester
pro one of them will probably help you
walk through it
and knock this down but that's the
general ideas of how you get at this
rodney
thanks for being a listener
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five riley is with us in kansas
city hi riley welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and dr john it's an honor to
speak to you guys you too what's up
so my wife and i got married back in
january
congratulations thank you sir um we
finished up baby step three
in march and we're trying to figure out
now whether we should move on to baby
step 3b
or move into baby step four with the
idea of throwing whatever else we can
into a savings account for a down
payment
eventually awesome good work man that's
incredible
so uh how old are you guys i am 23 and
she is 21.
what's your household income um it's
going to be
roughly 100 000 so she is
still in school she finishes in may and
she'll start working full time
in july awesome what's she going to do
she's an architectural engineer a lot
smarter than me well played man well
played
always good to marry up brother so what
do you do
i work in landscaping good very good
okay
all right so a hundred thousand dollar
household income you're in your early
twenties and you're thinking about
starting to save for a house what's the
downside
um well we're not entirely sure when
we know the place that we're living at
now we have a contract through
until next july and we're kind of
thinking
we'd potentially be in the position to
buy a house
maybe next spring but we're also not
sure
so i don't know if if it's
if we should you know save up and i
really wouldn't know how much exactly to
save up
or at this point and then start baby
step four or
start baby step four and throw whatever
we can well you got plenty of time to do
either
you're very smart very wise very ahead
of the game at your age
and so you're not calling me up at 62
with this question
you're already you're you know you've
already got you got 50 years here to
play this out so you're going to be fine
dude
you've done well so uh you're going to
get both you're going to get
retirement and you're going to get a
house so it's just a matter of what the
order
and what the first things are so what's
the in my mind
as young as you guys are i i would you
know how much to put down
i'll give you a hint the more you put
down the better off you're going to be
you can't put down too much it's
impossible
so um just start saving i mean once you
just pile up as much money as you can
pile up in the next 12 months
okay and guess what if you don't buy a
house then
you still got to build a pile of money
it's okay
okay and then you could start then you
could start your uh
baby step four and if you run numbers
from
you know 25 to 65 that 40 years
investing 15 of 100 000 that's going to
be like
15 million dollars
that's what you're going to have so my
point is if you if you put this off two
years and save for a house and
then start saving for retirement as long
as you do 15 the rest of your life
and that's if you never get a raise
which by the way if you work 40 years
and never get a raise you're a loser
okay so i think you're going to be okay
right you're following me i mean
the set of assumptions here is very
conservative is my point yes sir
yes sir you're going to do great i'll
just pile up as much as you can pile up
this year
just make it a game how much of a down
payment can we save
he sounds like a guy that
got in the football game and on the very
first pass
he made some good moves and scored a
touchdown and he crossed the line and
the crowd is cheering
he didn't know what to do with the ball
he didn't have a dance plan he does it
like do i just hand it back to the rep i
don't know what to do man
and it's just celebrate and then go to
the next step yeah
right it's this weird 23 and we are
crushing it and do we uh
touchdown dude it's awesome it's awesome
that's fun you've done so well sir
so well monique is with us in bangor
maine hi monique how are you
very well thank you to kelly for taking
my call today sure if you got by her
your life's good what's up
good move monique
so i am looking for some guidance from
dave and dr delaney about my will
i have two daughters one of whom
is doing very well financially she and
her husband are in the one percent
and the other daughter earns about 50
000 and
for several years i felt uncomfortable
about
how to like divide up the assets i'm an
everyday millionaire but more recently
i i've gotten to the point where i don't
want to give
either of them any money i i feel like
i've worked so hard my whole life
i paid for college for them i've paid
over half a million dollars for college
for them
and they've turned into socialists and
they just but they have
and and well you sit on the wrong
college
yeah you're my favorite call maybe in
two months
i know we're all laughing no we're with
you i'm depressed
i'm very depressed about where i
see my children heading and i think
i don't want my money to go to them
and i feel terrible about that you
shouldn't
they're not entitled they didn't hit the
dna lottery they're not entitled
my children have been instructed since
they were small
that in order to get the opportunity to
manage the money that god
gave me to manage meaning that i've hand
off the responsibility to manage some of
the ramsey fortune to them
they will have to be people of character
socialists are not people of character
okay there are parasites and so um
if my children are going to be parasites
i'm not going to finance their lives so
that they have a reality show
is there a way to put money in let's say
a trust where they couldn't get access
to
it to they were let's say 70 years old
i mean then they'd just be a 70 year old
socialist right
well but i i'm hoping by then they will
have
kind of woken up you can i put mine is
my
all of our estate is trust based and our
trust is
um we've done it from a faith
perspective not an economics perspective
but uh if they're not walking with god
they don't get to manage god's money
it's what the trust says really yep
in no uncertain terms and so uh
you know in your case you could change
that lingo and just go you know when you
become a capitalist you get the
opportunity to manage this money
monique here's what i would do i would
take some time to distill down beyond
the monikers and the
port on atlas shrugged what
that's fantastic um man i
am not usually at a loss for words and
you got me on that one um
monique here's what i want you to do i
want you to distill down
beneath the quote-unquote word socialist
okay what are the things that they are
saying that
concerns you that you think that you are
leaning into
and i want you to have a direct straight
conversation about what these
things are and then i want you to
identify them and like dave said it's
your mind you can do what you want to
with it
i i've seen more and more of the last
four or five years a lot of semantic
shale games and once you talk to
somebody it's like oh we're way on the
same page i just thought this about this
about that right
i think you can say that i you are not
required morally ethically legally
spiritually to leave your money to
people that you do not agree with how
they live their lives
period full stop in there right so
now once you've said that then you can
start to have some discussions with them
that are very gentle
and very life-giving and very correct
and very direct very kind and very clear
and it's like okay you know i've paid
for all this stuff for you
and truthfully i don't agree with the
way you're living your life and i'm not
willing to finance that going forward
right and so it's up to you if you want
to do that i'm not being controlling
i just want to let you know that i'm
going to go ahead and do a reading of
the will
and you're not going to be in it as long
as you're living this way whatever this
way is if your kid's a heroin addict
you sit down with them and go i'm not
funding your heroine but what you think
that is unique is you articulated what
that meant not it
you're not vague no no i'm very clear
very clear it's unbelievably detailed
and it costs
25 000 dollars very clear it's
ridiculous
yeah the legal field fees on this were
amazing but i just you know and and then
we get to have this meeting once a year
where we revisit and go oh by the way
remember what we said
if you're going to manage money for god
this is what managing money for god
looks like first you got to be walking
with him
and you know and we do this kind of
stuff and you don't get you know and so
it's not we're not mad about it we feel
a responsibility
heroin addicts are socialists you know i
mean it's like
wow this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ecclesiastes
311 he has made everything beautiful
in its time he has also set eternity in
every human heart yet no one can fathom
what god has done from beginning to end
agmandino said always do your best what
you plant now you will harvest
later so i think it's good to revisit
that last call
because it was not only highly
entertaining but it was um but the
concept needs to be talked about
uh we tell everyone to get a will 100
everyone needs a will
and i always tell people go ahead and
have a reading of the will while you're
alive
yes uh meaning tell people what the
flip's in it so that there's not some
drama after you're dead and
and that because what ends up happening
is you leave one of your kids as the
executor
and they have to execute what's in your
will and other people that are or aren't
in the will are mad
at the executor and you and i should
have been mad at you your executor to
shoot your arrows and that's not cool
yeah you need you need to go ahead and
take those arrows while you're alive
look you're not in this because have
some character right yeah you're not in
this because and it takes
it helps the family after your death
uh not be caught off guard and have all
these unmet expect i thought they were
gonna get a million dollars they got
nothing or whatever they thought they're
gonna get a hundred dollars they got
nothing
um or whatever right i mean so
go ahead and have a reading of the will
meaning you tell people what's in the
will okay
if i pass away this brother and sister
are gonna be the guardians of our
children
this person over here is going to be the
trustee of our life insurance proceeds
to
be given to those children according to
our trust and just let you know that
so that you know this other person over
here that thought they were going to be
managing both and getting either uh
they're they're well i wonder what i
wonder why he didn't do you know well
shut up you know i've already covered it
while i was alive that's right so you
have a reading of the will you do a will
while you're alive you tell people
what's up
you tell them where the will is yeah
where it physically is right and have
multiple copies so it can be found
um and it properly executed and you go
to mamabearlegalsform.com and you get
one you do in 20 minutes if you don't
have a complicated will
uh now when you're filling this out
you're going to discover the angst
that that that precious lady has
and that it requires thought about how
life works because you're planning your
death
it is the it is what your will is what
your
will like like you have a will um
it's what i want to have happen that's
my will upon my death
my last the last thing i wanted to have
happen my last will
and i testify to that a testament and so
then you sign it properly
and it becomes a legal document the
executor
is not in charge they don't have free
will
they get to execute executor execute
that's what that means they execute what
is in the will that's all they they're
not allowed to do anything else they're
allowed to just do what you said that's
all they can do
so you need to be real clear about what
they're supposed to do
very clear in there this is what goes to
that
and you need to update your will anytime
there's a major life change you change
states
because wills are not federal law
probate law is state law is not federal
law it's state law
and louisiana law is french based
uh you know uh and uh
you know very very different yeah we had
to update ours when we moved
yeah to new state and texas is uh it
still thinks it's
probably yeah so texas has got word laws
uh california
and uh florida very weird loss new york
ridiculously weird laws
most rest states are fairly similar but
still change your will update your will
if you change
if you go through a divorce obviously
you know you update your will
but the premise is pretty simple you are
not morally
or spiritually obligated to leave the
work of your hands to your kin
to anybody you don't want to period yeah
you're not obligated to leave it to
anybody
um and you're not a bad person if you
don't do that
by definition of having not done that
right they're not entitled
because they happen to have the same
last name they're not entitled because
they crossed your path
somewhere um and so
you know my dad's my dad's third wife
got everything
it's your dad's money it's your dad's
money he gets to decide that
maybe she was better to him than you
were or maybe
yeah maybe there's some issues and you
gotta grieve that yeah but that's not
you know you don't get to decide i'm
gonna fight it when you're invited if
you want you're gonna lose
yeah if the oil is put together right
and you should lose because it's not
his desire it's not his will that you
got the money
so so tell me how you think about this
i may have been told by a counselor in
my life that i'm hyper controlling
no and i have this this which makes a
great talk radio host by the way the
best
i have this fantasy about having money
that i pass along
and i'll be able to still pull strings
and i don't even be here
yeah good luck with that so there's part
of me that says i'm going to i want to i
want to detail this sucker out and y'all
are going to x y
and then there's part of me that knows
the futility of that and want to say
i'm raising two good kids i've got a
good
charities i believe whatever the thing
is and when i'm dead
it's how do you balance that well she's
got a lot more commas than zeros than i
did well what you've got to remember
is that when you leave money substantial
money it magnifies
well whoever you leave it to all their
good and all they're bad
so whatever's wrong with your kid is
going to be 10x and however generous
they are is going to be 10x 10x right
same thing with that charity if they're
if they're disorganized and chaotic
and they get a bunch of money they're
going to be 10x disorganized and chaotic
they're not suddenly going to fix their
deficits they're going to be magnified
uh they weren't waiting on the extra
money to clean up their act
and and so uh you know whatever wherever
you leave it so it's it's not
necessarily a blessing
and and so the extreme example we used
in that call is
uh you you leave a heroin addict money
you're gonna kill them
because they're gonna od because they
can finally afford it so you don't want
to you don't want to curse people
with your money with your money but
money's not the curse the curse is
you've magnified whatever's wrong
and whatever is right yeah and so and
you're not going to find any perfect
organizations
or any perfect kids and you're not more
spiritual if you left it to charity
than if you left it inside your family
you're still managing it for god if
we're christians
in either case and that's what we're
called to do so
how did you determine when you were
doing yours how did you determine
the character ethos that you wanted to
wrap around this money after you're gone
well i wanted them to be walking with
god and that also in our world involves
handling money the way we teach because
it's biblical principles
okay and so to the extent that they're
doing that
while i'm here i'm comfortable with them
being there and training them
that their brother or sister decides to
go off the ranch
and wants to live on the back of a yacht
and and not work
uh which is not in the bible and they'll
wrap around that and hold them
accountable yeah they're gonna go uh
you're not getting any more money got
you and they've got the tools to do it
the way we structured the thing
okay so um we're not gonna fund uh
i'm not name names but i mean crazy
people in reality shows you put the
names on them right right
uh they're pitiful and i don't want to
co i won't be the cause of the pitiful
uh not in my lineage you know and and so
but i'm not obligated to leave it to
charity because humans are bad
because humans run charities so this is
this is ridiculous
people well if you were spiritual you'd
leave it out of the church
where some guy that doesn't know how to
handle money is the pastor come on
that's a bunch of crap or you raise
three
off the charts generous children like
you have
and you know that money is going to be
magnified with the generosity right
and if they learn their lessons then the
same thing will apply as they leave it
to my grandkids or their grandkids
they're not going to ruin one of them
because if you fund
one that's off track you're going to
ensure they stay off track
that's what it amounts to and that's a
that's one being a charity
a ministry a person yeah and and so
that's what you gotta look at
in her case she's saying they became
socialist meaning she thinks that their
uh
their political view of the world is way
off base and she doesn't want to fund
that and she
and so and she disappointed a different
yeah different ideology
and so it's her money she can magnify
what she wants to leave it too
um conservative think tank i don't know
i mean you know whatever
i don't know but um whoever wherever you
feel like is going to implement that but
even remember then though there are
people running that
right and so the where the control
breaks down is when we all you know the
controlling from the grave the sense of
control freak that you and i both share
um breaks down is we realize
that even having done all of that then
it's still in god's hands because those
kids can still just go crazy they can do
what they want yeah they can come back
they can go away then come back then go
away
you know you could leave it to a
ministry and then they lose their way
and they completely leave
orthodoxy and go some crazy direction
with their theology and you go
how credit i leave money those people it
starts with
an articulation of what do you want to
see this money magnify i love that
yeah yeah because it's going to magnum
it's going to magnify it loves it
good discussion you guys and get your
wills done people do will
do a will this is the ramsay show we'll
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts